the Joe Rogan experience that was kind
of how police had total autonomy they
mean they they had so much power and
authority back then yeah it was crazy I
remember another incident this is right
before I left that I think I start
talking about in finish it was like they
had Tompkins Square Park and they were
trying that's when it was that area was
getting gentrified that was the big word
and there was like kind of a riot there
was all the people protesting the
gentrification of the Lower East Side
this was probably like I don't know
maybe early 90s late eighties and the
cops showed up on horseback
and I was I wish I had just walked out
to go to the deli I didn't even know
this was happening I just walked right
into the middle of like oh what's going
on here and then the cops just started
racing through the crowd and I just
started running and I saw a friend of
mine he died I'm he was a singer this
punk rock band Reagan Youth and I saw
this cop just jump on him and start
pounding on him so bad he had really
long dreadlocks the next time I saw him
his head was shaved and was all stitched
up because he just had so much damage to
his head he'd been like a coma or
something and then it was a big scandal
you could probably find this easily
because the cops all put black tape on
their badge numbers so that no one could
tell who was who while they did all this
[ __ ] and it was like on the front cover
the New York Post a picture of like a I
think the post the badge with the black
tape that [ __ ] was wild deck back then
see if we can find well then the Chicago
elections and the riots during the
1960's yeah was like a turning point in
Hunter s Thompson's life because he was
there and he watched these cops just
beat the [ __ ] out of people and he said
that he saw far worse beatings by the
Chicago Police than he ever saw for the
Hells Angels because you know his first
book yeah or the Hells Angels look so he
was around those guys for a year
watching them get into biker brawls and
[ __ ] he's like this [ __ ] paled it
paled I mean it's yes why but uh it's
crazy too but sometimes I being a cop
must be a crazy job horrific because I
can't imagine I mean I'm doesn't justify
stuff we're talking about but I can't
imagine how you
go crazy in that job right you see every
day and what you most of them I think of
PTSD and you know they don't it does
it's not addressed most people have
disdain for them
almost everybody they meets a liar yes
you mean a guy oh I didn't know how fast
I was going oh this is my house I just
can't find my keys like everyone's lying
to you and you're the enemy you are a
professional enemy and you were an enemy
outfit yeah for all these criminals a
enemy it's a terrible way to live yeah
you need them badly right it's in it's
no can't win on that job I don't think
no no you can't and it's and people
don't you don't get paid enough people
don't respect you they don't appreciate
you
you know I want you around no they want
you around yeah and then you're not
there fast enough
exactly yeah yeah it's uh I mean and cop
movies that's what's crazy is like cop
movies people love people love cop
movies and the cops are the good guys
yeah so strange but like their
interactions with humans in real life
like boy if people treated them the way
they think about them in the movies it
would be a wonderful time to be a cop
it's weird though because I remember
that time here in New York like so
strict like I have a different
relationship now when I see cops but but
as a as like a bum kid at 19 like I
remember walking down the street and a
cop would cruise alongside roll down the
window and they'd start taunting me
saying [ __ ] like you know police and
when it comes but they're just like
waiting for you to say something back
right and it was like was weird
you know I was just walking down the
street I wasn't you know AJ walking down
the street now whatever cop comes up to
me like oh no what's happening anybody
dude I saw you in Slayer it was [ __ ]
awesome is weird yeah it's gotta be
super strange yeah I mean the more
accountable now than ever before I think
that's one of the great things about
body cameras and cell phones cops are
you know you just can't rock it that way
before but I don't think they get enough
counseling and I don't think they get
enough money and I don't think that's I
don't think it's a stringent enough
screening process I think there's a lot
of people that are there you know there
are powerless [ __ ] when they're young
and they want
I just wish everybody's gonna [ __ ] if I
could be a cop and they become a cop for
all the wrong reasons and then there are
the ones that give the good cops a bad
name and if you think about the amount
of interactions that people have with
police and this is what perspective is
so important there are [ __ ] 320
million people in this country and cops
have millions and millions and millions
and millions and millions and millions
and millions of interactions with people
yeah all the time but how many of those
interactions are positive the vast
majority of them are not police
brutality the vast majority of men are
not shooting someone implanting a weapon
on them or planting drugs on them of
course a vast majority of them are cops
doing a really hard job and doing their
best but nobody gives a [ __ ] about that
you only care when the cops go bad you
know you know it's just perspective
which you know nobody has that's too
nuanced of a conversation with the world
now a new perspective on anything
[Applause]